نعم سهام قبل قليل او ربما في هذه اللحظات
لسدر ان كان يظهر في الصوره انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مخيم الفوار جنوب
الخليل قوات احتلال كانت متواجده بكميات
كبيره عند بوابه المخيم بعد ان داهمت
واقتحمت المخيم الثالثه فجر هذا اليوم
اندلعت مواجهات بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال
هذا الامر اسفر عن ارتقاء شهيدين الشهيد
احمد ياغي البالغ من العمر 17 عاما
والشهيد ابراهيم اطي
البالغ من عمر 31 عاما اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه عن استشهادهم اثر مواجهات
اندلعت ما بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال في
مخيم الفوار اضافه الى اصابتين ايضا
بالرصاص الحي هذا كان حصيله هذا الاقتحام
الذي انتهى للتو قبل قليل حيث كما ذكرنا
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال عند مدخل او عند
بوابه مخيم الفوار جنوب الخليل قبل قليل
وقف او تجمع جنود الاحتلال باعداد كبيره
وبداوا يؤدون طقوسا تلمود ويلتقطون صورا
تذكريه والحقيقه ان هذا المشهد جرت العاده
في الاونه الاخيره عند الانتهاء من كل
اقتحام لمخيم الفوار وهذا هو الاقتحام
الرابع للمخيم منذ السابع من اكتوبر بهذا
الشكل او بهذه الضخامه و بهذا العدد من
الجنود عند الانتهاء من كل اقتحام يتجمع
الجنود عند هذه البوابه التي تظهر امامنا
مباشره باعداد كبيره يلتقطون الصور
التذكاريه ويؤدون طقوسا تلمود طبعا مخيم
الفوار يقع جنوب الخليل مساحه كيل مر مربع
يسكنه 14000 نسمه يتعرض بشكل مستمر وبشكل
متواصل في الاونه الاخيره الى اقتحامات
شبه يوميه تقوم قوات الاحتلال خلال هذه
الاقتحامات باطلاق الرصاص وقنابل الغاز
السام المسيل لل تموع باتجاه المواطنين
كما يظهر في هذه الصوره ايضا سهام معاناه
المواطنين جراء اغلاق قوات الاحتلال
للبوابه الحديديه عند مدخل مخيم الفوار
هذه بوابه مغلقه تماما منذ السابع من
اكتوبر لم تفتح ولو لدقيقه واحده يضطر
المواطنون ان يسلكوا طريقا جانبيه وهذه
الطريق محفوفه بالمخاط